hi Matt here with a quick request we'd
love your help and guidance we've
created a short survey on LinkedIn to
get your input on areas you'd like to
learn more about take a minute to visit
our thinkfast talks smart LinkedIn page
to complete our brief survey while there
please also follow us you can follow us
on Instagram as well finally for those
of you who listen on Spotify we are
loving your responses to our episode
specific questions keep them coming as
always you can learn more at faster
smarter. where you'll find quick tip
videos our newsletter English language
learning materials and information about
my new book think faster talk
smarter when it comes to change and
persuasion we must think deeply but
communicate simply welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast I'm Matt Abrahams
and I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
today I am super excited to be joined by
Francis fry who is Professor of
technology and operations management at
Harvard Business School Francis served
as Uber's senior vice president of
leadership and strategy along with Anne
Morris Francis hosts the fixable podcast
and together an and Francis wrote
unleashed the Unapologetic leaders guide
to empowering everyone around you and
their new book move fast and fix things
The Trusted leader guide to solving hard
problems
welcome Francis I have enjoyed getting
to know you over the last few years and
I look so forward to our conversation
today oh I'm so thrilled to be here Matt
thank you for inviting me absolutely so
let's get started you study and advocate
for the value and importance of trust in
leadership can you share some strategies
and tactics leaders can use to build and
support trust yeah so the first thing is
to realize that many of the sayings we
hear are not true so it takes a long
time to build you lose it in an instant
it can never be rebuilt none of those
statements are true my first strategic
advice is treat trust like you treat
everything else you want to build
understand its component parts build it
up if something happens and it and it
gets wobbly go back in and Shore up the
part that got wobbly you don't have to
shore up the rest of it just the part
that got wobbly so treat it as something
that you build and let go of all of the
myths around it so it sounds to me like
we need to think of trust as something
that's ongoing that we're constantly
monitoring and and measuring and making
sure that it it's the level we wish it
to be and if not we we Dive Right In and
fix it is that right I would say is that
when you're earning trust you can think
about other things and anytime you have
Skeptics of one for Source or another
treat that with precision and urgency to
go in and Shore up what was in the place
and then get it back up to humming along
and then I think you don't have to worry
about it quite as much anymore excellent
and and you talked about the different
components so I'd love for you to
describe for us your trust triangle what
it is and how we can use it and I want
to follow up on what you just said as
well when you notice that trust is
weaker than you want it what are some of
the things you can do to dive in and and
work on it terrific essentially the
component parts are authenticity logic
and empathy and what that means is that
I am more likely to earn your trust you
are more likely to trust me if you
simultaneously experience my
authenticity my logic and my empathy if
you are blocked from experiencing any
one of those three you're not going to
trust me that's when we say it gets
wobbly that's when when we have Skeptics
we're trusted most of the time so
authenticity logic and empathy are
cooking they're going but every single
time trust breaks down between
individuals between any stakeholders
between organizations anytime it breaks
down we have always been able to trace
it back to one of these three and then
we get to go get to work on which one it
is because you'll find that the
prescriptions are very different for the
three of them so we really have to get
that matching right that's really
helpful to have that that rubric or key
available and it strikes me Francis that
reflection is really important in this a
lot of us I myself included when I feel
trust is at risk I I I get frustrated
and I feel like I'm doing everything I
should why don't these people trust me
and it it sounds like I have to take a
step back and really reflect on what's
Happening look at the three that you've
mentioned and then try to figure out
where it is so I can at least make some
adjustments yeah so I'd say Matt you
gave away a little bit of a tell that
you might have an empathy wobble I'm
doing everything right why don't they
trust me that's a pretty classic empathy
wobble here's what I would say I wonder
what it is about my communication that's
getting in the way of them see how I
just flipped it back so because when
people say we have to be self-reflected
I don't always know how to do it but I
know how to do what I just did with you
which is get curiosity from the other
person's perspective I love it thank you
not only have you helped me but you've
demonstrated what we can all do for
ourselves and for others and thank you
critically important to take the time to
reflect and and to think about how you
can reverse the situation to help give
the Insight that you need many of those
listening work for organizations that
are in various stages of implementing de
diversity equity and inclusion programs
based on your experience what are some
of the best ways to implement assess and
reinforce Dei programs so we have found
that the best way is to think about the
letters d e and I and and change the
sequence so the most important of these
three letters is I it's inclusion it's
the one that should be done first when
we get inclusion right diversity and
Equity often follow but many times I see
organizations get diversity right and
equity and inclusion may or may not
follow so I think the first thing is to
realize that the focus should be on
inclusion and now we have a very
specific understanding of how to
accelerate inclusion in any organization
but the the crisp answer to the question
is focus on inclusion and you're going
to go at a much faster pace and get to a
much higher Place great I I love the
idea of starting with inclusion can you
give a little more detail into the
specifics of what inclusion looks like
are there are there stages and steps we
can pay attention to yes indeed so
there's four stages of it and the stages
are safe welcome celebrated championed
and the way to think about it is that
each of us brings magnificent difference
to the table right you're at Stanford
I'm at Harvard and then we could then
list another 20 differences between us
and they're magnificent and the way to
think about inclusion is that despite
any difference that we're bringing to
the table we have to set the conditions
so that each of us feels
safe once we've achieved safety and only
once we've achieved safety we graduate
to welcome which is a lighter and
Lovelier thing that happens but don't
worry about welcome if you don't have
safety once we have achieved safe and
welcome then we want to start
celebrating one another for our
uniqueness and I think this is the part
that matters instinctually we often
dwell on what we have in common we look
for the common ground and that sounds so
good the problem is the more difference
we have the less common we have and
everything that you and I have in common
is a little
redundant I want to know how do you
think about the world differently than
how I think about the world that's when
we're both collectively going to be
better off so we want to learn the
practice of celebrating
uniqueness and we want to celebrate
uniqueness in one another's presence but
also in one another's absence and we
champion people when I am invited into a
room for example that maybe others
aren't invited into and I speak on their
behalf I'm championing them and so it
goes safe welcome celebrated champion
and that's the what we talk about is how
do we move people up the inclusion
dial without moving anyone else down the
inclusion dial and that's the if I'd say
in 2023 when there's a lot of
controversy around Dei I think much of
it can be found in that concept we're
afraid of moving some people up at the
expense of moving others down and so we
have to be clever in how we do this I
really appreciate that articulation of
the different steps it really helped me
to focus on the different strategies and
communication approaches I would take
depending on where we are and what what
I do to build a sense of safety is very
different than what I do when I'm
celebrating I love that and and I think
it's important for us to realize that
it's a whole toolkit we need it's not
just one big approach uh I want to turn
our attention to your new book move fast
and fix things you and an your co-author
and co-host on your podcast and wife uh
strive to accelerate excellence in
organizations by helping them as you say
build and learn quickly while also
avoiding costly mistakes you do this
essentially by providing A playbook for
how to fix things fast and you represent
this methodology based on a weekday
calendar can you walk us through the
five steps in your playbook essentially
walk us through Monday through Friday so
we've organized the book by days of the
week Monday identify your real problem
we're often presented with the symptoms
but we got to trace back to what the
real underlying cause is so it's
identification day Tuesday whatever your
problem is if it involves human beings
trust is broken rebuild trust at the
center of your problem Wednesday when
you're looking for how to do all the
other things you have to do in addition
to rebuilding trust well you want to go
out and get as many gorgeous New
Perspectives as you can so we call it
make new friends but really deliberately
go and find people who don't think like
you what we often say when people gather
around the table which perspective is
missing look for who's not at the table
and go and invite them in so Wednesday
is make new friends Thursday your
favorite day I believe is storytelling
day which is whatever awesome Solutions
you've come up Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday if you don't communicate it
well it's as if you didn't come up with
an awesome solution so we really focus
on how to tell a great story and then
once you've done Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday now you have license
to go as fast as you can so we call the
book move fast and fix things it's
really a counter to move fast and break
things right that that Mark Zuckerberg
made famous but many people really put
out at at least implicitly you can
either go fast or you can take care of
people one or the other in our mind they
gave speed a bad name we find if you do
it this way you can go faster when you
fix things than if you broke
things but you can't do the speed day
any earlier than Friday you actually
have to go through Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday and then you're
in a position to go as fast as you can I
really appreciate you breaking that down
the background work you do allows you to
go quickly obviously and this is not
going to surprise you or any of our
listeners uh I want to linger a little
longer on Thursday I have a couple
questions I'd like to ask when you tell
your stories do you have a particular
structure or way of formulating those
stories to really have them impact I
like the question so the first thing is
that for us stories have a past present
and future and it's really important for
us to be super deliberate about each one
so when we talk about how the good old
days it's it's important to honor what
happened in the past both the good of it
and the bad of it because it might have
been good old days for some and not for
others hence we need to change right so
honor the past both sides of Honor for
the present you know very few of us want
to change unless we have to and so we
need a super clear and compelling change
mandate why do I have to change now can
I change next week what about next month
you know next quarter would be more next
year would be more convenient all of a
sudden it's like just in the ever ever
distant future so why do I have to
change now the the joke we often make is
that if you're a retailer and Walmart
opens up next door super clear super
compelling well we have to be that clear
and that compelling in our story of why
now for this change and then the future
which is okay you want us to change to
what and there's two aspects of the
future that we find to be super
necessary it's got to be rigorous you
can't describe some Fantastical thing
and it has to be
optimistic so people are not going to
follow us if you're going to like well
we got to go to the Future and it's
going to be
grim nobody's nobody's getting behind
you but nor are people getting behind us
when we're like come on it's going to be
great and we're like why is it going to
be great oh it just is not going to work
so we find that honor the past have a
clear and compelling change mandate in a
rigorous and optimistic Way Forward that
provides the necessary architecture for
telling a great story telling a great
change story and I guess that's what I'm
saying is that this change goes from
yesterday to tomorrow that structure of
past present future is one that you can
see in lots of very motivational
presentations and and stories that
people tell and I appreciate you
breaking it down and the tone with which
you deliver it as you mentioned there is
also important it needs to be optimistic
it needs to be motivational and and
incentivize people to want to strive for
it so I appreciate that structure very
much I'm a huge fan of structure and and
I the past present future structure I
think is ideal for what you're
describing I I want to keep going though
on this uh you write that the foundation
of persuasive communication
communication that will change the way
people think an act is to understand
something so deeply that you can
describe it simply can you unpack that
for us I love these questions so I find
that when people describe things in
simple terms it's either because they
understood it so deeply that they can
describe it that way and that will move
me or they understood it super
officially so and only one of those is
going to move me to action like if I can
say there are three components of trust
they authenticity logic and empathy I'm
now describing that very simply well
that I can do that because I understand
it so deeply now more often than we
would like when people understand
something deeply they use a very
complicated way to describe it so I
understand it deeply I describe it in a
complicated way the problem is you then
speak to just a very few people only the
people that can also participate so if
you want broad influence if you want to
have broad
persuasion we have to understand it
really deeply and then describe it in a
simple and compelling enough way that
others can take action and to me it's so
that others can take action in our
absence and that's where the Simplicity
part comes in that's very clear those
who've listened in before have heard my
favorite saying that came from my mother
although I'm sure she didn't originate
it tell me the time don't build me the
clock and and I think that fits well
with what you're saying is you have to
understand how to build the clock but
not everybody wants to know how you
built it they just want to know the time
and they want to align with that so
thank you I am curious if you can talk a
bit about emotion in Persuasion though
yeah
so first of all I will just say that we
think that emotions are
underused and there's almost like I've
heard so many people give advice you
know don't be so emotional like contain
your emotions and I find that to not be
correct in most instances I want people
to bring more emotion emotion is like
the sanding that we can then come and
paint on top of emotion really makes us
absorptive so I want us to bring our
emotion but I want us to be able to
harness them and use them correctly so
to me not only is emotion make us
three-dimensional instead of
two-dimensional but I think we have
greater absorptive capacity in its
presence I love a good analogy and I
love the notion of emotion is the
sanding you do before you paint and it
makes things more absorb absorbent
that's lovely and I think that that that
is a perfect way to Envision the role of
emotion in communication and
persuasion last thing I'll ask you about
communic unication uh you've been around
organizations a lot you studied them
what are one or two of the biggest
communication mistakes that
organizations make we mistake having
said it for your having heard
it I told them as if that
matters I am so uninterested in giving
participation trophies in life but
really in this aspect of life I want to
know did they hear it your notion of
just because you've said it doesn't mean
that it's been heard is one I want to
put a big exclamation point after I
think that is so important and I see
that play out in my own personal life as
a parent as a partner as well as a
teacher and I think all of us can
imagine circumstances where hey we've
said it so therefore it's done without
really checking for did somebody hear us
and what could I have done better to
make it clearer so thank you for
identifying those mistakes and and
highlighting how we need to address them
before we end Francis I'd like to ask
you three questions are you up for that
I'd love it so my first question for you
is your book talks about five days
Monday through Friday Saturday and
Sunday aren't on that list what are we
doing on those days oh very importantly
the week has two days of rest and
recovery and that's how everything
should work you do the work and then you
have the rest in recovery as a former
athlete I knew that my muscles were
built while I was resting so I had to do
the workout but the recovery is when I
would actually show the gains and so
it's the week has a week end and I think
it's a really important metaphor uhuh
absolutely I I find myself and I I know
many others use the weekend to catch up
on work and what I'm hearing you say is
take the weekend to rejuvenate you just
substituted the recovery for an extra
day and that's going to catch up on you
that that's going to catch up on you
absolutely question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
well my revealed behavior is that I
consume a great deal of comedians
stand-up comedy is just something it's
it's very difficult for me to imagine 48
Hours going by without me consuming some
standup comedy so I'm a connoisseur of
that and I think because they get the
simply deeply they understand an
observation so deeply that they can
describe it simply you know how many
reps it took them to do that like a 100
500 a thousand so they also honor the
craft of communication which is it's
hard to go deeply and then to get it and
and I might even say that comedians are
deeply simply
funny and that's like the art form I'm
trying to understand things deeply so I
can describe it simply they're doing
that and then they're also making it
funny wow that's like another level it
is amazing to me the depth of experience
practice and work that comedians put in
I have a cousin who's doing very well as
a comedian and I've interviewed several
and you're absolutely right and and I
like how you phrased it though the the
simply deeply funny that's that's the
Crux of what they do and if I could give
a shout out to the two comedians I find
myself listening to over and over again
so it's I already know what they're
going to say and I still want to listen
to it and that's that's saying something
it's Wanda Wanda
Sykes and Kathleen
Madigan and I think these two cover a
spectrum that's probably wide enough for
your listeners that they're going to
appreciate at least one of them I I
enjoy both of them uh I'll let you in on
a little secret Francis one of the
things I do as part of my nightly ritual
to help me relax and turn off my brain
is every night before I go to bed I'll
listen to a five minute comedy routine
and both of those comedians are are in
my playlist uh my go-to is Robin
Williams I have a a just an admiration
for his ability to be spontaneous all
right question number three what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe I think
intention which is what's the point of
my communication and again no
participation trophy my intention is to
influence the culture as an example so I
think intention is the is the first part
of it two is determination to do the
hard work like if we go to our favorite
standup comedians who really like Jerry
Seinfeld is still practicing four or
five nights a week and you know how many
CEOs I see go give a really important
talk after two
reps so intention hard work whatever
that word is but we like let's refine it
and let's honor it as something that can
get better and better and better and
then the third one I'm going to say is
Joy which is communication you mentioned
earlier that communication is thought of
as a necessary evil I want to I want to
reframe that for people communication is
the thing that is going to let us unlock
unimaginable progress so let's look at
it as the gift that it really is
communication truly is a huge unlock and
thank you for sharing those three
ingredients absolutely critical that
tenacity piece is really really
important well well Francis thank you I
knew we would have a great conversation
I appreciate you introducing us to
Concepts around trust around culture Dei
and how to fix things fast good luck
with your new book thank you so much
thank you very much Matt and I get why
you have a podcast on communication you
are a beautiful Communicator why thank
you you've been listening to another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast a production of Stanford
Graduate School of Business this podcast
was produced by Jenny Luna Kevin Patel
and me Matt Abrahams with special thanks
to Podium podcast company to find more
episodes visit our website at gb.
stanford.edu or find us wherever you get
your podcasts including YouTube for more
business related content follow the
business school on social media at
Stamford GSB you can also find the
podcast and follow us on LinkedIn and
Instagram